whatever is begun in anger
ends in shame
i didn't fail the test
i just found 100 ways to do it wrong
life's biggest tragedy is that we get
old too soon
and wise too late
there are three faithful friends
an old wife
an old dog
and ready money
[Music]
never leave till tomorrow
that which you can do today
time is money
well done is better than well said
no gains without pains
one today is worth two tomorrows
laziness travels so slowly that poverty
soon overtakes him
rather go to bed without dinner
than to rise in debt
at 20 years of age the will reigns
at 30
the wit
and at 40
the judgment
to succeed
jump as quickly at opportunities as you
do at conclusions
lost time is never found again
an investment in knowledge pays the best
interest
where there is marriage without love
there will be love without marriage
haste makes waste
if a man empties his purse into his head
no one can take it from him
three may keep a secret
if two of them are dead
many people die at 25
and aren't buried until they are 75
never ruin an apology with an excuse
he that lies down with dogs
shall rise up with fleas
doused thou love life
then do not squander time
for that's the stuff life is made of
educate your children to self-control
to the habit of holding passion and
prejudice
and evil tendencies subject to an
upright and reasoning will
and you have done much to abolish misery
from their future
and crimes from society
keep your eyes wide open before marriage
half shut afterwards
we do not stop playing because we grow
old
we grow old because we stop playing
work as if you were to live a thousand
years
play as if you were to die tomorrow
contentment makes poor men rich
discontent makes rich men poor
beware of little expenses
a small leak will sink a great ship
you will find the key to success
under the alarm clock
vice knows that he is ugly
so he puts on a mask
having been poor is no shame
but being ashamed of it is
if you would know the value of money go
and try to borrow some
he that displays too often his wife and
his wallet is in danger of having both
of them borrowed
fatigue is the best pillow
the discontented man finds no easy chair
to find out a girl's faults
praise her to her girlfriends
love your enemies
for they tell you your faults
buy what thou hast no seed of
and air long
thou shalt sell thy necessities
you may delay
but time will not
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments
don't miss out on a chance to see the
next video subscribe